GREAT WAY TO END THE "THE STORY.
THE STORY CONTINUES, WE WILL SEE
YOU TOMORROW NIGHT AT SEVEN.
ON TUCKER IS.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE SAD NEWS IS, AND YOU KNOW
THIS ALREADY COME MORE THAN
22 MILLION PEOPLE I FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS RECENTLY
SINCE OUR GOVERNMENT BEGAN
IMPLEMENTING MASS QUARANTINES
AND SHUTTING DOWN THE ECONOMY IN
STATE AFTER STATE.
43% OF ALL AMERICANS HAVE SEEN
THEIR HOURS CUT, THEIR PAY CUT
OR LOST THEIR JOBS ENTIRELY.
THAT MEANS A HUGE CHUNK OF THE
COUNTRY IS WONDERING HOW TO PAY
THE BILLS.
SOME HAVE RUN OUT OF MONEY
ENTIRELY AND THEY ARE HUNGRY.
LINES AT FOOD BANKS ARE THE
LONGEST IN NEARLY A HUNDRED
YEARS SINCE THE DEPRESSION.
SO WHATEVER YOU THINK OF OUR
UNIQUELY GENEROUS IMMIGRATION
POLICY, MAYBE YOU SUPPORT IT,
IT’S PRETTY CLEAR THAT RIGHT NOW
IS LITERALLY THE LAST MOMENT
THAT UNEMPLOYED AMERICANS SHOULD
HAVE TO BE UNDERCUT BY FOREIGN
NATIONALS AS THEY LOOK FOR
DESPERATELY NEEDED JOBS.
IT’S OBVIOUS AND THE PRESIDENT
KNOWS IT WELL.
LAST NIGHT WITHOUT WARNING HE
TWEETED THIS.
"IN LIGHT OF THE ATTACK FROM THE
INVISIBLE ENEMY AS WELL AS
NEEDING TO PROTECT THE JOBS OF
OUR GREAT AMERICAN CITIZENS I
WILL BE SIGNING AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TEMPORARILY SUSPENDING
IMMIGRATION INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THAT SEEMS TO COME OUT OF
NOWHERE.
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN CONSISTENTLY
DEMANDING THIS AND IT’S
MEASURABLE.
I KNEW ABSALOM’S POLL FOUND A
REMARKABLE 79% OF AMERICAN
ADULTS SUPPORT THE TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF ALL IMMIGRATION
INTO THE COUNTRY FOR THE
DURATION OF THIS PANDEMIC.
A HARVARD HARRIS POLL FOUND THAT
83% OF ADULTS WANT A MORATORIUM
ON IMMIGRATION FROM MEXICO.
AND THESE ARE NOT NEW
SENTIMENTS.
ANOTHER HARVARD POLL FROM TWO
YEARS AGO FOUND THAT 81% OF
VOTERS WANTED LEGAL IMMIGRATION
CUT TO BELOW ITS CURRENT LEVEL.
AT 63% WANTED THAT NUMBER CUT BY
HALF AT LEAST, AND IN A COUNTRY
IS DIVIDED AS OURS IS RIGHT NOW
THIS IS AS CLOSE TO A CONSENSUS
AS YOU ARE EVER GOING TO FIND
ABOUT ANYTHING EVER.
IF OUR DEMOCRACY IS REAL AND WE
ARE HOPING IT IS, OUR LEADERS
CANNOT CONTINUE TO IGNORE WHAT
THE PUBLIC WANTS.
IN THIS CASE THERE’S NO QUESTION
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DO WHAT HE HAS DONE.
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZES THE PRESIDENT, ANY
PRESIDENT TO SUSPEND IMMIGRATION
INTO THE COUNTRY WHENEVER HE
DEEMS IT DETRIMENTAL TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES.
DURING HEARINGS AT THE TIME THEY
EXPLICITLY POINTED TO EPIDEMICS
AND MASS EMPLOYMENT AS THE KIND
OF CRISES THAT WOULD JUSTIFY
CUTTING OFF IMMIGRATION.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
OF COURSE IT DOES.
TWO LESS PEOPLE IT MAKES UTTER
SENSE.
WHY IN THE MIDDLE OF A DISASTER
WOULD YOU MAKE THINGS WORSE.
WHY WOULD YOU HURT YOUR OWN
PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE ALREADY
HURTING?
EVEN IN EUROPE THAT’S VERY
OBVIOUS TO LEADERS, MANY
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES HAVE CLOSED
THEIR BORDERS DURING THIS ESTER
AND ARE NOW MAKING DO WITH THEIR
OWN INDIGENOUS LABOR FORCE.
AND YET SOME PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY STILL OPPOSE THE IDEA.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE AND WHY DID
THEY OPPOSE IT?
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PAMPERED
AND ENRICHED BY WAVES OF LOW
WAGE AND MIGRATION ARE AGAINST
IT.
POLITICIANS WHOSE HOPES FOR
POWER REST ON CHANGES IN THIS
POPULATION OPPOSE IT, TOO.
THEY WOULD RATHER SEE AMERICANS
UNEMPLOYED.
ANYONE WHOSE LIVELIHOOD DEPENDS
ON SELLING OF THE COUNTRY IS APT
TO BE VERY THREATENED BY IT.
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT IS SQUARELY
IN THAT CATEGORY.
SHE SPENT THE LAST 20 YEARS
BOWING BEFORE AND PROFITING FROM
THE GOVERNMENT OF COMMUNIST
CHINA.
SHE LOBBIED FOR THIS DISASTROUS
COMMISSION INTO THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION 20 YEARS AGO.
SHE’S NOW APPALLED BY THE NOTION
OF CUTTING IMMIGRATION DURING
THE WORST UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS OF
OUR LIFETIMES.
IS SHE JUST EXPLAINED ON MSNBC
THAT’S IMMORAL.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S MESSAGING ON
IMMIGRATION?
>> I’M STUNNED.
I DO THINK THAT THE STATUE OF
LIBERTY IS WEEPING.
IT’S UN-AMERICAN.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
IT’S UN-AMERICAN TO ACT IN THE
ECONOMIC INTEREST OF AMERICA.
AND BAIDOA WORK IS TECHNICALLY
UNEMPLOYED HIMSELF, ERUPTED IN A
PRIMAL SCREAM.
HE SAID "WHO DO YOU THINK IS
WORKING ON THE FARMS AND
FEEDLOTS AND PACKING PLANTS AT A
TIME WE ARE STRUGGLING TO FEED
OURSELVES.
WHO IS IN THE KITCHEN, WHO IS
PICKING AND PREPARING AND
SERVING THE FOOD WE EAT AND
CLEANING UP AFTERWARDS?
HONESTLY, THOSE ARE ALL VERY
GOOD QUESTIONS IF YOU ARE AN
18TH CENTURY FRENCH MARQUIS.
AS A COUNTRY FALLS APART AROUND
HIM, HIS FIRST AND MAIN CONCERN
IS PRESERVING AMERICA’S SACRED
TASK SYSTEM.
THE NATIVE-BORN WORKING ON FARMS
AND KITCHENS AND FACTORIES?
IT’S UNNATURAL, UNTHINKABLE,
IT’S WRONG.
WE MUST HAVE A COMPLIANT
UNDERCLASS.
WE MUST.
WHO WILL IRON THE SHEETS?
YOU CAN JUST IMAGINE SITTING
ALONE IN HIS STUDY FOR WRITING
ABOUT THE COMING PEASANT
REBELLION.
BUT IT TURNS OUT HE NEEDN’T HAVE
WORRIED.
JUST BEFORE AIRTIME THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THE
SUBSTANCE OF HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER, AND IT’S POSSIBLE THIS
WILL CHANGE.
BUT IT’S THIS.
THE NEW MORATORIUM WILL LAST FOR
60 DAYS AT WHICH POINT IT WILL
BE EXTENDED OR NOT BE EXTENDED.
THE BAND WILL APPLY TO ONLY
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING PERMANENT
RESIDENCY IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN OTHER WORDS PEOPLE WHO LIKE
THE UNITED STATES ENOUGH TO STAY
PERMANENTLY AND WOULD LIKE GREEN
CARDS TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
LEGALLY.
BUT THE BAND WILL NOT APPLY TO
THOSE ENTERING THE UNITED STATES
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS AND THAT
MEANS THIS WILL NOT AFFECT
GUEST WORKERS.
THAT’S AN AWFUL LOT OF
EXCEPTIONS.
EVERY YEAR THE GOVERNMENT HANDS
OUT 80,000 NONAGRICULTURAL
GUEST WORKER VISAS, AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AQUA WORKER
VISAS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS TITLE WAVE
OF IMMIGRATION HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHAT ADVOCATES OF
IMMIGRATION CLAIM IMMIGRATION IS
FOR.
THESE VISAS DO NOT IMPROVE
AMERICAN SOCIETY IN ANY WAY.
WE HAVE NO MORAL OBLIGATION TO
GIVE THEM, NO MENTION OF
GUEST WORKERS ON STATUE OF
LIBERTY.
THERE’S ONLY ONE POINT IN
HANDING OUT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF THESE VISAS TO
FOREIGN NATIONALS AND ITS
DUPLICATE BIG BUSINESS.
EMPLOYERS ALWAYS AND EVERYWHERE
WANT TO HIRE WORKERS FOR LESS,
IN THIS CASE LESS THAN AMERICANS
MAKE IN THESE VISAS LET THEM DO
IT.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO IT AT A TIME
WHEN MORE THAN 22 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE JUST FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT.
YOU MAY HAVE JUST LOST YOUR JOB
BUT YOU WILL BE HAPPY TO KNOW
THAT ACCENTURE CAN STILL IMPORT
I.T. WORKERS FROM ASIA WHO WILL
WORK FOR LESS THAN HE WANTS ME
TO.
SO IF THE POINT OF THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS TO PROTECT
AMERICAN JOBS, MAYBE THERE WAS
ANOTHER POINT.
BUT IF IT WAS TO PROTECT
AMERICAN JOBS, IT FAILED.
SO HOW DID THIS HAPPEN EXACTLY?
WE AREN’T SURE ALTHOUGH WE DO
PLAN TO FIND OUT.
BUT FOR NOW WE CAN MAKE A FEW
EDUCATED GUESSES.
THE FIRST IS THIS, THE PRESIDENT
IS WORRIED ABOUT PRESERVING
AMERICAN JOBS.
HE SAYS THAT FREQUENTLY TO
PEOPLE AROUND HIM AND HE CLEARLY
MEANS IT.
HE RAN ON THAT ISSUE IN 2016 AT
A COURSE, HE ONE ON THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, AND THIS SEEMS TO
BE KEY, SOME IN HIS ORBIT ARE
NOT CONCERNED.
AND IN THE MIDDLE CLASS IS DYING
AT A FASTER CLIP THAN EVER
BEFORE AND THIS WILL NOT HELP
THEM.
BUT THAT’S NOT THE PROBLEM OF
THIS ADVISOR.
I DON’T KNOW MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE PERSONALLY ANYWAY.
THESE PEOPLE MAY NOT BE POOR BUT
THEY ARE FASHIONABLY POOR.
THEY WRITE SONGS ABOUT AND RAISE
MONEY FOR MIXERS.
THEY ARE JUST NORMAL AMERICANS
WHOSE LIVES AND FUTURES AND
FAMILIES HAVE TAKEN A TERRIFYING
DIVE THAT THEY MAY NOT RECOVER
FROM, BUT WHATEVER.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WITH
INFLUENCE HANGING AROUND THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE MORE PROFOUND
THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT RIGHT NOW
THAN THE FATE OF AMERICA’S DYING
MIDDLE-CLASS.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHETHER
THEIR FRIENDS WILL APPROVE OF
THE PRESIDENT’S LATEST EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
THAT’S THEIR ATTITUDE AND IT’S
THAT ATTITUDE THAT BROUGHT US
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.